okay so would you introduce yourself my
name is I'm a journalist a campaigner
for women's rights but the government
called me
ugly duckling Troublemaker the agent of
CIA the agent of musad the agent of MI6
wow I have so many different names how
could they ever call you an ugly
duckling this is ridiculous because they
don't know the end of the story of ugly
duckling
the end of this one yes
so what should the people at home know
about your story or know about your
struggle and just understanding freedom
and rights against tyrannical
governments ah my God it's not easy
actually to say that even in America I
was not safe just because of fighting
against the Islamic Republic because you
know millions of people might think that
okay the regime in Iran arrested
protesters killed protesters arrest the
activists journalists women's rights and
then we're going to be six miles away
from Iran nope that happened to me like
uh in New York City in New York City on
July the FBI stopped the kidnapping plot
the regime were trying to kidnap me take
me to a speed boat to Venezuela and
arrest me I mean kidnap me from
Venezuela to Iran a lot of people might
think this is like a movie but this is
our history like the Islamic Republic
targeted more than 500 Iranians outside
Iran either kill them assassinate them
or kidnap them and I'm only one of them
just last year a journalist from France
were tricked to go to Iraq and then they
kidnapped him from Iraq then they
executed him in Iran so basically this
is the nature of the Islamic Republic
and I'm here actually to trust I mean to
let the rest of the world know that this
is not just about us Iranians this the
Islamic Republic Taliban Isis no
difference they are like coronavirus
they can infect the rest of the world
that seems to be a similar theme here
like if you look around people are
obviously here attending and and people
are basically saying this is tyrannical
governments across the world it's not
yeah and I was when I finished my my
talk a woman from Turkey came and gave
me a hug and saying that I I feel your
pain you know a woman from I mean
different not just getting hugs from All
Sorts hey hey hey I'll give you a hug
too yeah
so that actually what I want look the
dictators are more united than Freedom
Fighters This is all we need look at
around the world dedicures from like
Taliban Russia
turkey different like Venezuela all the
dictators are united you that's a very
profound statement you just made you're
saying the dictators are more united
than the Freedom Fighters exactly why do
you think that is
I'm gonna tell you why here in America
where do you see the left and liberals
supporting like the women of Afghanistan
right now and they are in the streets
look one travel ban happen Muslim ban
happened people were in the streets when
burkini ban happen in France people were
in the street condemning that wait a
minute millions of women are forced to
wear chadori for gang in Afghanistan I
mean the hijab like Taliban one millions
of women in Iran even girls from the age
of seven they are forced to wear hijab
if they don't they're gonna kicked out
from school they won't be able to live
to exist in their own country I myself
receive videos from women of Afghanistan
women of Iran saying that we are not as
scared we are fighting the Islamic
Republic in Taliban but where are the
rest of the world are you waiting like
uh Taliban to be recognized and then
fight back no this is the right time we
have to push by Administration we have
to push the European government to stand
solidarity with the women of Iran
Afghanistan women of all the world when
it comes to feminism
bury your political agenda stand with
your values that's all I want to you
know see around the world if you're
really a true feminist you have to
Keep The Sisterhood doesn't matter who
is in power Obama is in power Trump is
in power Biden Israel who cares just
support your sisters that's all I want
in in America I you know I don't want to
be presumptuous but a lot of us are born
into Freedom we haven't had to fight
with tyrannical governments or ever had
to lose our freedoms
still I'm not safe here so it's not it's
not just about me Islamic Republican
Taliban is a threat to America so it
doesn't you might say that we we were
born for Freedom we're gonna keep it no
to me freedom is or democracy is
something that we every individual us
should protect democracy otherwise we're
going to deal with Taliban or Islamic
Republic or terrorists or Isis in
America what about the people that would
say well the taliban's not coming to
America they're not coming after our
freedoms what would you say to those
people this is wrong September 11th you
think it's just gone no
the same Taliban the same like Isis and
this the Islamic Republic actually uh
send their own terrorists in America in
Germany in Paris and they killed a lot
of like none like dual National citizens
and non-iranians they are in prison in
Iran and they're being used like
bargaining chip
this is what I say you might think that
you're safe here but if you keep silent
about our fight against dictators you're
not gonna be so other than speaking out
how do you fight against these dictators
or is it just speaking out and being an
activist how do you fight no we need
action we need action look when uh the
kidnapping blood happened about me a lot
of people were speaking up
keyboards secretary blanken actually
said that we condemned that I said I
don't need a condemnation take an action
what type of actions would you like to
see the first action which is a small
action but it's it's a victory for for
me that they sanctioned four people who
were actually responsible about
kidnapping me from from New York but
look when the
blarucian activist was kidnapped what
happened the EU sanctioned and they took
a strong action when like German the
Islamic Republic actually assassinated
many discipline Iranian dissident in
Germany years ago and then the EU took a
strong action we don't want the European
government the American government
doesn't matter what kind of political
view you have we don't want you to
legitimize social regime which in 21st
century kill women lashes women for just
being their true self
is that too much to ask this is 21st
century and I get kicked out from my
homeland just because I want to be my
true self my say my body my choice this
is 21st century I cannot get an
education I cannot get I I won't exist
if I say I don't want to follow Sharia
law final thoughts just like for people
that don't understand your struggle
there's a lot of people that just go
about their business they wake up they
take freedom for granted they they live
in the comfort of America they don't
have to worry about the concerns that
you have you're living in New York City
and you almost get kidnapped by the
Islamic Republic speak to the people
that are just like all right why should
I be concerned with this type of stuff
wake me up is there anything you want to
say oh that's a very good question
because a lot of people think this is
about human rights I activists this is
about journalists this is about Iranians
this is about women in Taliban no it's
not it's about you every individual you
watching me it's about you because as I
told you Isis Taliban and the Islamic
Republic is a
it's more deadlier than chronovirus and
they are gonna spread their own ideology
everywhere everywhere and if you don't
stand solidarity with your sisters in
Iran and Afghanistan then you have to
deal with Taliban and Isis and Islamic
Republic in your own land and believe me
human rights is not something like
internal matter it's a global issue hug
me support me and be with me and
millions of other women I can go just
have fun and ignore about everything but
I don't want to do that because this is
about my dignity to uh fight back all
the dictators I love it and with a hair
like that why would you ever want to
wear a hijab right exactly I cannot even
cover them up
thank you so much
[Music]